[Music]
on this thursday night keep calm and
keep counting as the last ballots are
tallied in america's presidential
election
could today be the tipping point we'll
know very soon
the potential paths to power the
mounting pressure from trump supporters
to stop the count they will not give us
access
the groundless claims about fraud and
cheating
and joe biden and canada how a potential
change at the white house could affect
the great white north
plus getting canada's economy to recover
from covet 19.
this is a very very complex situation
striking a balance between health
and wealth
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
from washington the presidential
election
was tuesday it is now thursday evening
and we are still in a holding pattern
not all the ballots have been counted
in some states where the races are very
tight this could be a decisive day or
it might not be here's where things
stand right now
according to numbers from associated
press democratic candidate joe biden is
holding at 264 just six electoral
college votes away
from 270. that's the number needed to
win the white house republican donald
trump is at 214.
votes are still being counted in five
key states they're shaded in gray on
this map
in pennsylvania north carolina georgia
and nevada the margins are razor thin
a win in any of those states would give
joe biden the presidency
moments ago donald trump gave a long
rambling statement at the white house
that was filled with lies
we're only going to play a short clip he
claimed that
he has won and is being cheated out of
victory
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us if you count
the votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly
there is no evidence of illegal voting
what is being counted are perfectly
legal votes many of them mailed in
because of the pandemic
and trump is on track to lose right now
he just can't seem to
accept that joe biden delivered a short
statement this afternoon his message
be patient we have no doubt
that when the count is finished senator
harris and i will be declared the
winners
so i ask everyone to stay calm all
people to stay calm
the process is working the count is
being completed
and we'll know very soon
eric sorenson is going to take us
through the numbers and the potential
path to victory in just a moment
mike armstrong is in philadelphia
pennsylvania where
counting of the mail-in ballots is close
to finishing we
understand we'll start here in
washington with jackson prescott jackson
the biden team
calling for patients sounding very
confident though sending signals they're
preparing to take power
they really are if you look at the tone
and tenor of former vice president
biden's speech today it seemed to be an
attempt to sound
presidential he was also sort of filling
a void here left by what had been a
prolonged silence from president trump
we went
almost 40 hours without seeing the
president on camera that's highly
unusual
and really this is about reassuring
biden's own supporters his message to
them is
we've got this just give us time to
finish counting the ballots but really
he is
sounding very confident tonight and then
donald trump did emerge tonight of
course at the white house and
give a rambling statement saying he's
being cheated out of victory
uh is that catching fire with anyone i
mean apart from his most
die-hard supporters yeah i think this is
the question we need answered because
there were 69 million people who cast
ballots for president trump but i think
you're right there's a smaller group
that really hang on every word and take
these types of things seriously
we need to point out time and time again
the president has been unable to produce
any evidence of fraud the campaign has
tried court challenges
in four or five states now they keep
falling apart because they can't produce
evidence and it's almost like they're
using the courts to further push
disinformation
by making a big splash about going to
court and then not delivering at the end
of the day and donna that really extends
to the fact that trump campaign is even
asking supporters now
to help them find proof of voter fraud
because it's just not there
they don't have it they haven't been
able to produce it yet all right jackson
thanks i'm gonna come back to you to
talk about what this election might mean
for the balance of power in washington
but first we want to look at the maps
and the mass eric sorensen is tracking
the tight races tonight
eric bring us up to speed
donna the polls closed almost 48 hours
ago but in several states
it's still like election night a record
number mail-in ballots that have
extended the time to get a final count
and razor thin races
that give joe biden and the democrats
confidence but also give donald trump
and the republicans hope
here are some of the races to watch
still pennsylvania
the president has a lead but it is
shrinking as mail-in votes are counted
north carolina close but many expect
trump will ultimately win
georgia biden has narrowed the gap but
they are running out of votes to count
nevada biden is ahead just a few
thousand votes
and arizona where it has been called by
associated press
global news partner the race there
though has tightened since election
night
it is frantic and nerve-wracking as
several states count ballots knowing
that their outcome could determine the
presidency
in pennsylvania democrats sent in the
vast majority of mail-in votes that are
being counted now
and making it closer by the hour people
of pennsylvania and the american people
want answers from pennsylvania
i can assure them maybe going a little
slow but it's going very very smooth
under any scenario there is no path to
victory for president trump without
pennsylvania
i feel very good about pennsylvania
virtually all the remaining battles to
be counted were cast by mail
president trump tweeted stop the count
of course he doesn't want that in states
where he trails
only where he has a lead that he wants
to freeze before all the votes are
counted
what cannot be ruled out however is a
very close comeback win for trump
biden's lead in electoral votes 264 to
trump's 214
puts biden very close to the 270 needed
to win the presidency
of the outstanding states trump expects
alaska to go his way soon
he must however run the table on the
other states pennsylvania
north carolina georgia and nevada to go
over the top
biden only needs nevada to go his way to
reach 270 and win
according to associated press another
wrinkle
trump and some organizations are keeping
arizona in play
which would take 11 electoral votes away
from biden
but circle back to pennsylvania put that
in biden's column
and it's all over all the outstanding
states even clawing back arizona to
trump
would not get him from where he is to
270. biden taking pennsylvania alone
wins the presidency while joe biden has
more paths to victory
the more close finishes there are
ironically the more challenges
legal and otherwise that are potentially
available to president trump
donna all right eric sorenson in toronto
thanks
jackson we haven't talked about this
much but it looks like the republicans
will retain control of the senate
what might that do for joe biden if he
becomes president
and ironically this actually speaks to
sort of how ridiculous the president's
election rigging claims are because
republicans down
ballot did really really well here
you're right the control of the senate
is going to go to a runoff quite likely
in
georgia in two different races
republicans could well be poised to hang
on to it
democrats do have control of the house
but big picture this means they're going
to struggle with their agenda even if
joe biden becomes president so
those wishlist things they talked about
like potentially expanding the supreme
court
or making washington d.c a state those
would have to wait and even on a more
practical immediate matter when you talk
about things like
a relief package for the ongoing
pandemic that would be at the whims of
what republicans want if republicans
maintain control of the senate
a lot of unhappy democrat legislatures
legislators excuse me
based on those results and a sign of how
divided this country still is jackson
thank you pennsylvania is still counting
ballots
its 20 electoral college votes could
decide the presidency
but the counting in one of that state's
biggest counties has
stopped mike armstrong is in
pennsylvania mike we're talking about
allegheny county that's
the area around pittsburgh what's
happening
yeah donna it's a little strange but
completely normal county officials put
out a press release overnight
explaining what's happening and why
there's basically they have two groups
of ballots that require a little bit of
extra scrutiny so they took today
to do some administrative work and
they'll be back at counting tomorrow
morning
at 9 00 a.m now why did those two groups
of ballots require extra scrutiny
well the first group's about 29 000
ballots that were sent out with problems
on them from the vendor and they had to
be reissued county officials have to
make sure that no one for example
sent in two ballots even by accident the
other group is about six thousand
ballots that have some sort of a mistake
on them
something like a smudge from a printer
something like that so they're not
scannable now in some cases those
ballots can still be used but it takes
extra time so again in pittsburgh
they'll be back counting tomorrow
morning
but here in philadelphia the counting
continues
it's not a race but more of a grind vote
counters in the convention center in
philadelphia are processing and adding
up ballots at a pace of about ten
thousand an hour as they go about it
this democratic leaning county and the
ones around it
cut into donald trump's lead more and
more
now that is frustrating some this is the
scene outside the convention center a
protest
by trump supporters i don't trust those
mailing votes
i just don't trust them because anybody
can send anything
across from that protest another
demonstrators who say
every vote has to be counted i'm out
here because our city
of philadelphia the city of brotherly
love works so
hard to mobilize many many many voters
now as contentious as this is it's also
something else
completely predictable this come from
behind phenomenon is something political
scientists call the blue
shift and it's something they've been
studying for years
all the jeeps are voting right now
that's right basically democratic voters
across the u.s
adopted mail-in and early voting before
and in bigger
numbers than republican voters thank you
this was a group dropping off ballots in
york county more than a week
before the election now donald trump for
the most part dissuaded his supporters
from voting early
ready to vote so as the early votes are
counted
late in the process biden's closing the
gap
that is likely a major factor in why the
trump campaign
is fighting tooth and nail they have
eight attorneys fighting us
two trump campaign officials are
complaining again today about
access to the counting process a
frustrated corey lewandowski
going so far as to tweet out private
phone numbers for a city lawyer
what is going on in this city what are
you hiding
open up the doors let us in let us six
feet away
so that we can have a free and fair
election
now the counting is a slow process and
the fighting over it continues but for
donald trump
it's not that there's a lot on the line
here in pennsylvania everything's on the
line there is no
path to victory with for him without
this state
donna okay mike armstrong in
philadelphia thank you
a little later we'll check in with jeff
semple who's in michigan a state that is
flipped in biden's favor
first though over to the west coast to
portland oregon some protesters have
taken to the streets there
sarah mcdonald reports
with the national guard activated in the
streets
this once vibrant downtown district
looked ready for battle
on wednesday destructive demonstrators
descended upon
by three levels of law enforcement a
riot declared as windows were smashed
and buildings vandalized now it's
election week things have picked back up
a little bit
but this was likely regardless of the
outcome of the presidential election
in fact the damage and the unrest
nationwide isn't as severe as expected
the protest culture partisan or not
thriving in portland where the store
logan pedicolas works at was targeted
again it's the death of small business
in downtown i mean even the fact that
we're having to put boards up in the
first place is another nail in the
coffin
in michigan and arizona
republicans some heavily armed stormed
vote counting centers
convinced a core pillar of the
democratic process is rigged
a dangerous conspiracy theory only
further fueled by
president donald trump if president
donald trump won the election he was
going to burn the cardboard
i meant the plywood and the city down
most americans like jacob smith
are still just struggling to survive the
pandemic
politics aside let's get back to to get
back
we're already dealing with one thing
this co-bid thing so we don't need to be
dealing with that too
the prospect of civil unrest in whatever
capacity
only deepening the growing division
driving a wedge
through the united states that division
only expected to be exacerbated once
this election
is called the national guard remaining
on standby hear the state of oregon
still under a state of emergency
that could be extended donna
all right sarah mcdonald in portland
thanks what if joe biden becomes the
next president
coming up what that could mean for
canada
global national is back from washington
in a moment
welcome back to washington if donald
trump does not win
a second term that will change the
dynamic of america's relationship with
all its allies
including canada our chief political
correspondent david aiken has been
looking into what a joe biden presidency
might mean
david well donna the single most common
thing that i'm hearing
is that a joe biden presidency would
bring some stability and predictability
some peace to the white house and the
value of that to many on this side of
the border cannot be overstated
for example when it comes to the economy
businesses
need to be able to plan for the future
but trump's constant retaliatory tariffs
or
threats of tariffs made that impossible
removing that threat alone
will brighten investment prospects in
both countries
but biden has also said that he will
block the keystone pipeline
and that will be a major concern for
many on this side of the border
but biden is doing this because of his
commitment to reducing greenhouse gas
emissions
and on that file the trudeau government
is expected to work
in lockstep with the biden
administration to harmonize
environmental regulations and costs
right across
north america finally think about
foreign affairs and defense
a change in who's who in the white house
would likely mean a
big change in attitude on russia that
affects canada's work in ukraine
and towards china that could change the
outlook
for the two michaels currently being
held hostage by china
donna lots of things at play
david aiken in ottawa thanks balancing
act still ahead the pressure on
provinces to juggle public health
and the economy
you're watching global national
[Music]
we've been talking about numbers all
week as we cover the u.s presidential
election but there's
another number affecting the lives of
canadians the rising number of covet 19
cases
everyone is living under some kind of
public health restriction right now
and as mike trolley explains it is a
tricky balance between keeping people
healthy
and avoiding economic hardship it was
not a good news budget for ontario by
any means
in a year ravaged by covet 19 how could
it be
premier doug ford laid out his plan for
recovery and when the pandemic is over
ontario will come back with vengeance
stronger and more prosperous than ever
before
but it's the path for balance that's
still uncertain
ontario's seven-day average for new
cases continues to rise
even as restrictions are lifted in areas
that have yet to show much improvement
like peel region but epidemiologists
argue with everything they've learned
about covet 19 this year
lockdowns should be only used as a last
resort this is a very very
complex situation i think that we really
have to try to look at
all the factors rather than just
simplifying it between health and wealth
in quebec it's been 10 days since red
zone restrictions were extended until
november
a move that hasn't been popular with
businesses the province's seven-day
average of new cases is still high
but it's leveled off and unlike doug
ford premier francois lego
isn't loosening the reins the most
critical situation is in manitoba
where a series of outbreaks in long-term
care homes has threatened to overwhelm
hospitals
and the numbers point to worst days to
come the province's positivity rate for
testing
is at a critically high 8.9 percent what
that's telling us is that what they're
finding on the ground in terms of their
cases is probably just the tip of the
iceberg
and that iceberg is certainly blocking
any path to recovery
mike relay global news toronto
the michigan model next what led a swing
state to flip
back to its blue roots we're back from
washington
in a moment
welcome back to washington michigan is
one state that had record voter turnout
this year
donald trump nearly won the state in
2016 the first time it's gone republican
in more than 25 years
as jeff semple explains this year the
president's pandemic policies and
leadership style motivated lots of
people in michigan
to vote against trump hamtramck
michigan's most densely populated city
is home to a diversity of cultures
and politics some of them as democrats
some of them is republicans
this business owner voted for donald
trump in 2016 but this time around
he along with the rest of the state
flipped to the democrats especially the
the whole corona how he handled it was a
big letdown big big big huge letdown
that kind of
put everybody's life in danger this
swing voter says during trump's term he
was subjected to racism
which ultimately swayed his vote for joe
biden he's
attacking the muslim and the people have
spoken
and with the election behind us now is
the time for us
to find common ground and come together
but biden's supporters aren't
celebrating just yet
citing fears that the fight isn't over
we are
praying and wishing a peaceful
transition
late wednesday trump supporters tried to
force their way into the building where
the ballots were being counted echoing
the president's calls to stop the count
and prompting police to step in a small
group of trump supporters were back
outside the building where the ballots
are being counted
again today and they like the president
are claiming fraud
and promising to fight
outside tensions erupted once again
between biden
and trump's supporters i witnessed
ballots that were mismatched braden
giacobazzi was one of the republican
party's designated
election observers allowed inside he
claims he was often prevented from
seeing the ballots and you'd have to get
up close to do that because you can't
see it from six feet away
and they would step in the way and
accuse us of trying to endanger their
life because of covid
they wheeled it covered like a weapon
but a michigan judge denied trump's
request to halt the counting which is
now complete
these tensions and allegations of fraud
even without evidence
fueling fears about the potential for
violence once a winner
is declared jeff simple global news
detroit
and that is global national for this
thursday from washington d.c i'm donna
friesen
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye